welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they all float with
Pennywise now out of its 27 year
hibernation and now making its way
across cinemas worldwide it's time to
dive into its latest movie and breakdown
everything that you need to know about
it
throughout this video I'll be going over
the main plot points of the showdown
between the killer clown and the losers
Club and discussing my interpretation of
the movie and its ending there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the film yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for click in this
video now let's get into my breakdown of
it chapter 2 after the horrifying death
of Adrian Mellon and a number of
disappearances in the town of Derry it
becomes clear that Pennywise has
returned to the surface once more Mike
who has remained in the city observing
any strange occurrences that happen
there calls on his old friends from the
losers Club to remember their oaths and
pleased with them to return to the town
to stop the creature once and for all
each of them other than Mike has went on
to have successful careers but this
phone call that they receive makes them
slowly begin to remember their
childhoods and also the terror that
awaits them some simply cannot handle it
and Stan commits suicide I will fear
which we later discover is because that
it feels that this would have held them
back in their final fight I'll discuss
this more later down the line but I have
to say it is a very interesting new take
on the character Beverly is once more in
a toxic relationship and similar to her
childhood is dealt abuse by her husband
Tom Rogan who contrary to the source
material and miniseries is in the film
very little bill who was always a
metaphor for Stephen King is a married
writer who has trouble finishing stories
this is kind of an interesting allegory
for the book itself and how it finishes
and the movie actually takes a huge
creative Liberty at the end
changes it up quite a lot from the
source material juxtaposing the original
miniseries Belle's wife similar to Tom
Rogan is absent for a lot of the movie
in this series she was captured by Tom
and then taken to Pennywise where she
was sent into a vegetative state but
this is completely missing which i
personally think is a smart move as that
was a pretty lackluster part of the
adaptation and original work Ben is a
successful architect however he also
suffers from alcoholism and still
possesses unrequited love for Beverly
which is also a driving force for him
returning to the town Eddy is still a
hypochondriac and has pretty much went
on to marry his mother literally and
similar to Beverly he finds himself
trapped in a cycle of an happiness the
biggest change up comes in the form of
Richie who like the source material is a
famous comedian that enjoys national
acclaim but the movie changes him
drastically in the fact that he's
actually gay and is in love with Eddie
this sort of mirrors Ben's affection for
Beverly and whilst that may sound
slightly jarring to people who weren't
expecting such a turn I actually think
that the movie pulls it off really well
especially due to haters performance
Eddie in the miniseries always struck me
as gay and they did change up his adult
life slightly to make it so that he was
a virgin and I think this relationship
and attraction makes a lot of sense and
sort of flashes out Richie more than
we've ever had before as in the past he
was pretty much a 1 know character that
was used predominantly for comic relief
a lot of the time anyway they reunite in
a city - Stan and discovered that not
only are things far worse and when they
were children but that Pennywise is also
out for them as adults he's far more
vicious than he was 27 years prior and
from the off it's clear that this is a
completely different beast altogether
there's far more gore and the movie
feels a lot more mature than the prior
entry now those expecting to see a film
poor Pennywise will be very disappointed
I think as the character or rather the
form isn't in the film that much well it
itself does pop up often there's not
really much of the clown which I was
hoping to see more of as bill skarsgård
is spellbinding in the scenes that it
gets the losers Club begin to recount
their childhood and throughout Pennywise
torments them as he continues his reign
of terror showing just how helpless they
are against
it's terrifying and it's a huge step up
from the prior film that shows why they
must stop the cycle there's a huge scene
in which we revisit the losers Club back
when they were younger and I've noticed
a lot online that there's a criticism
about the de-aging effect which I agree
comes across pretty poorly I don't know
why the creative team decided to try and
do this as it falls completely flat and
massively took me out of the film whilst
the child actors have grown up I don't
think that it would have been as bad to
see the actors as they are carrying out
this dialogue - the effects Marvel
really set the bar high with their D
aging and unfortunately this massively
pales in comparison seeming almost
laughable at points whilst it's not
enough to break the film it is quite
head-scratching and will probably be a
big critique against the film going
forward now not long after this we
discover Pennywise is origin story and
the group uncover the way to defeat him
which is known as the ritual of tchard a
metaphysical movement that will destroy
the creature on a psychic level and
finally vanquish him the group look for
totems from their childhood that will
help to empower them so that they can
finally face down against the creature
however this turns out to be one big
bait and switch which I'll get into
later Henry Bowers returns and whilst he
is slightly underdeveloped he still acts
as another hurdle between the losers
Club and their final showdown after he
dies they return to near bolt house and
Pennywise uses all of the elements from
their childhoods to try and make them
remember the fear that has haunted them
for so long it's an awesome scene that
by far best the original movie and acts
as a trip down memory lane
it even switches up the Stanley head in
the refrigerator scene and uses him as a
child rather than an adult there's an
awesome thing reference and I think many
fans of horror will love but finally the
group make it to penny wise is lair here
they're given a real test and it looks
like beer is slowly overcoming them as
they begin to deal with the enormity of
that task they head into the lair and is
even a reference to the tale from the
book as they go into the final showdown
the ritual of chert fails and is nothing
to penny wise and mike reveals that it
didn't actually work initially but he
believed that due to their self belief
they may have been able to overcome it
penny wise using its psychic abilities
transforms reality around them
while it's changing into the spider
creature that massively breaks them down
mentally reminding them of all the
trauma that they've been through most
notably Beverly which is when the most
blood on screen and a scene moment
happens however with the love that
exists between the characters they are
able to get each other out of it Ben
saves Beverly and vice versa Ritchie's
belief in Eddie strengthens him bill
apologizes to a vision of Georgie in
which he admits that he lied about being
sick as a child and that he just didn't
want to play with him that day it's a
really heartbreaking moment that
completely recontextualizes the film and
in my opinion is one of the best reveals
in the movie bill sheds the guilt and
along with the rest of the group at this
moment they break out of the spell they
fight the creature head-on and in this
scene we also get another big death from
the book Eddie attempting to save
Ritchie tries to spear Pennywise but
unfortunately he is impaled by the
creature which eventually leads to the
character's death this inspires the
group to no longer fear Pennywise and as
it's no longer able to thrive on fear it
shrinks to a point that the losers are
able to finally kill the character by
ripping out its heart in the finale
though the losers Club wind it's a very
bittersweet ending we see Ritchie
carving R + e in the same way that
people often do with a teenage crush
which shows that he's really lost the
love of his life it's a tragic reveal
that really hits home and cements that
we all have regrets in life that we wish
we had the time to go back and change we
learn of Stan's true intentions through
a letter in which he reveals that if he
had have came back to dairy that
Pennywise would have become stronger due
to the beer that he had for it and this
would have probably meant that they
would have lost it's a nice little twist
on the original work I think Stan's
death always felt a bit kind of
underdeveloped to me and lacking in
purpose whereas this really drives home
that it wasn't in vain and in the end
that he did do it for the right reasons
rather than purely because he was a
coward people who commit suicides often
express feelings of being a burden upon
others and this adds a lot of weight to
the thinking behind why Stan made the
choice that he did Ben and Beverley
start a relationship together and Bill
and Mike discuss Stan's letter and Mike
finally states that once and for all
he's going to leave Jerry
mike has pretty much been told
throughout his entire life that he'll
never be
successful and this mentality is the
main thing that's always held them back
and has been the reason that he stayed
behind in Derry
now the character finally feels like he
can let go and start a new life and it's
inspiring to see him grow in the end
though it's a complete change from the
original book and miniseries I think
this works a lot better and it ends the
film on an emotional high but what did I
think of the movie overall well whilst I
did enjoy it do you feel like it was
impeded slightly by the length which at
some points can seem meandering there's
also an issue with the lack of Pennywise
which is one of the main things that
people come to see this film for I think
when reading the book and even watching
the miniseries the strongest element for
me was always a children's story this
was easy to relate to and who doesn't
remember growing up being scared of
things that now seem laughable I
remember when I was about four I got
told by a group of teens that they lived
a troll on a reservoir next to where we
lived and for many years I was too
terrified to even go up there now this
seems laughable these days but stuff
like that made me really find
commonality with this story of it
chapter one and I think like many the
adult section just didn't appeal as much
which is why myself and other critics
are having difficulty pricing the film I
mean that was a part of a book that
pretty much went on to inspire the
entirety of stranger things and there's
just so much good in there that it
completely overshadows their lives as
adults now there is room it to be a
director's cut that clocks in at four
hours in which I think that elements
such as Henry Bowers storyline will be
explored in more detail perhaps making
for a more enjoyable film even if longer
that's not to say it's bad though and it
chapter two deals with a lot of its
subjects in a mature and adult manner
that do still make one of the most
interesting horror movies of the last
decade or so it to me has always been a
metaphor for sexual assault and whilst
many may not agree I think that there's
a lot of evidence to support this we
follow characters who went through
traumatic experiences when they were
younger with an adult-like figure who
seemed untouchable by the law and was
something that wasn't discussed openly
Pennywise is almost an open secret in
the town though no one ever really
brings it up these characters repress
their memories only to confront them
years later and finally put an end to
happened to them as youngsters Pennywise
himself even evokes images of the
infamous serial killer John Wayne Gacy
who famously dressed up as a clown and
while Stephen King has never
acknowledged that the story is inspired
by him the fact that Gacy was arrested
you in 1978 when King began writing the
book is hard to ignore
either way this cements to me that when
dealing with such storylines that a
sense of maturity has to come with the
work and its attitude definitely carries
that without it feeling heavy-handed or
off-putting for people who just want to
watch his simple horror film with a few
jump scares the acting of the piece is
phenomenal most notably Bill Hader who
took Richie from one of my least
favorite out of the group to the best by
Barth
he was always annoying in the pasta me
but bill embodies him with an
outstanding performance that adds far
more gravitas to the character than
we've ever seen before
overall it Chapter two is an enjoyable
ride albeit a slightly disappointing one
from what I was expecting and whilst it
has a lot of highs and does develop the
source material in an interesting way I
think it still pales slightly when
compared to chapter 1 and that's why it
gets seven point five out of ten
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it chapter two and if you agree with
me or not comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full plot leak of Joker which
would be linked at the end a go over
everything you need to know about the
movie so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just wanna let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of John
wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave it
thoughts on it chapter 2 in the comment
section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from the end to a bigoted
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]